[Música]
bienvenidos al programa de medio
ambiente de france 24 que una vez más
llega a producido desde casa esta semana
nos vamos a honduras
este era el momento en el que se conocía
la sentencia unánime contra roberto
david castillo mejía como coautor del
asesinato de la líder ambiental
hondureña bertha cáceres en marzo de
castillo arrestado en 2018 era uno de
los directivos de la compañía de
desarrollos energéticos de esa encargada
de construir una represa en el río
walker que sagrado para la comunidad
indígena lenca y a la cual se oponía
cáceres tras años de retrasos y varias
suspensiones del juicio que finalmente
inició el 6 de abril el tribunal de
sentencia nacional de honduras dio a
conocer su fallo el lunes 5 de julio el
ministerio público hondureño calificó de
histórica la sentencia y admitió que las
pruebas eran irrefutables
de la prueba evacuada en el debate
durante dos meses la sala primera del
tribunal de sentencia con jurisdicción
nacional consideró que la extracción y
vaciado de información en dispositivos
celulares del imputado y otros
involucrados fue lo suficientemente
reveladora para establecer que castillo
ordenó la muerte de cáceres como parte
de un plan para eliminar cualquier
obstáculo que interfiriera en las
operaciones de desa sobre el río walk ar
que territorio ancestral del pueblo
indígena lenca según el abogado de la
familia cáceres lo importante de la
sentencia es además que define el móvil
del crimen y lo relaciona directamente
con el activismo de berta así se lo dijo
a nuestra corresponsal en honduras kenia
torres
a nosotros nos parece relevante es que
en la argumentación en el desarrollo del
fallo
pues se rescatan los planteamientos
fundamentales que hemos venido teniendo
desde las víctimas desde todas las
organizaciones que nos hemos involucrado
en el proceso que conocemos el juicio
rescata que el móvil del asesinato está
relacionado con las reivindicaciones de
berta cáceres del copinh del pueblo
lenca de ríoblanco de sus derechos
frente a la violencia que instaló el
proyecto hidroeléctrico aguas arriba en
diciembre de 2019 ya habían sido
condenados a entre 30 y 50 años de
prisión otros siete hombres a quienes se
les acusó de ser los autores materiales
del asesinato de berta todas estas
condenas dejan a familiares y compañeros
activistas de berta cáceres satisfechos
pero recuerdan que hay muchos
responsables de su muerte que aún
permanecen en libertad es bueno decir
que nosotros estamos plena plenamente
satisfecha de los esfuerzos que hemos
hecho más de cinco años del crimen de mi
mami porque contra
no es contra un sistema impunidad contra
los grupos económicos haciendo presión
para que davis as que fuera disculpados
hemos logrado un fallo de culpabilidad y
por no decir que él es la pieza clave
que abre la puerta a la autoría
intelectual pero que también hoy se le
rinde homenaje a la memoria de verdad
eres una pues luchadora de este país que
justamente luchó contra él y judía y por
los derechos de la población teníamos la
certeza desde hace 5 años gente que da
vida es tirar a culpable de quedar y
castigar a responsable de planificar y
en vez de línea obligar cada que
amenazar y de asesinar a nuestra
compañera estamos contentas y seguimos
en resistencia porque también tenemos la
certeza de que con david castillo no
termina esta lucha leyendo un comunicado
del consejo cívico de organizaciones
populares e indígenas de honduras copinh
co fundado por la propia cáceres su hija
berta mencionó a varios integrantes de
la familia ata las habla una de las más
poderosas de honduras y a quienes acusan
de haber proporcionado el financiamiento
para llevar a cabo el homicidio
el fallo condenatorio emitido por este
tribunal significa que las estructuras
de poder no lograron en este caso
corromper al sistema de justicia y que
la estructura criminal de la familia
está las habla de la cual es instrumento
el condenado dedicación mejía no logró
sus objetivos segundo reafirmamos que la
causa berta cáceres de justicia en
honduras no termina o es la resolución
sino que se encamina firmemente para
llevar ante la justicia a los autores
intelectuales del crimen
daniela a la mente
y demás personas espirituales
además zúñiga recordó que ella y su
familia están siendo objeto de
violaciones ya que se les ha impedido
varias veces el acceso a las audiencias
y pidió que se revoque la concesión de
la represa hidroeléctrica agua zarca que
consideran ilegal y corrupta que no
seamos el maltrato sistemático y
constante a las víctimas por parte de
los funcionarios públicos es inadmisible
que una víctima en su proceso se le
informa que la palabra no se le niega
obstaculiza la entrada a un recinto
judicial habrá que esperar hasta agosto
para saber la pena que se le impondrá el
condenado que podría ser de hasta 25
años de cárcel
mientras tanto david castillo tendrá que
permanecer en prisión preventiva la
familia de berta cáceres por su parte
seguirá luchando para asegurarse de que
todos los responsables de esta y muchas
otras muertes de defensores de la tierra
y líderes sociales sean condenados una
lucha imprescindible en el país con más
asesinatos de activistas ambientales per
cápita es todo por esta semana hay más
medio ambiente en france 24 punto com
[Música]